Now that we've covered
activity content transitions,
let's move on to shared
element transitions.
Let's start off by taking
a look at why they're useful.
Now when changing the state of your UI,
motion can help you to explain
that change as well as focus your
attention on the content that matters.
So, in this example, the album cover
remains throughout the transition
between an artist's screen and album
screen, smoothly moving into place.
The transition is organized around
the object that you selected, and
it unfolds from your touch.
It helps to keep you oriented.
We call this a shared element
transition as the album cover
is shared across the two states.
Even if your UI doesn't
include rich imagery for
you to transition between states,
you can use these same principles to
convey navigational relationships.
In this example, clicking on an item
in the list causes it to lift up,
forming its own surface,
and then expand into place.
This reinforces the parent
to child relationship.
That you're drilling down into an item.
The motion guides the user
between the two states.
We can also take advantage of
this advanced paper material
which can transform its size and
shape and position.
This helps us to move between
states within a screen,
not just across screen boundaries.
So in this example,
clicking on an event in your calendar.
The material lifts up into
its own separate surface and
then transforms into
the Event Details page.
These examples all help to provide
continuity between different states
in your UI to create a more
understandable experience.